[Musique]
e
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle signature view on aurait voulu
avoir vos points de vue respectifs sur
l'actualité numérique sur la loi
renseignements sur des questions de
terrorisme de géopolitique on va donner
la parole à jean-marc manach jean marc
manach qui êtes vous
je suis journaliste je suis devenu
journaliste par hasard journée des
investigations par hasard sur internet
par hasard et j'ai trouvé ça vachement
bien au fait de creuser j'ai trouvé
plein plein plein plein plein plein
plein de trucs et et voilà je suis
journée sans indépendants aujourd'hui
plus rattachées à une rédaction
particulier il faut collaborer avec
quels types de médias et vous avez
collaboré avec quels types de médias
j'ai plus en plus de télé là cette année
j'ai travaillé pour france 4 avec vice
et pour mission qui s'appelle notre jt
mais qui s'arrête parce que je pense
qu'à des lignes chaîne familiale
je pige régulièrement au canard enchaîné
j'ai travaillé arrêt sur images j'ai
longtemps travaillé pour revenir fait
pas mal de datajournalisme et
je pige de temps entre peut-être un peu
avec google et j'ai pas mal bossé écoute
il x la crise qui êtes vous
pas déjà pas mal pamart crise marque
grèce
tombait dans le journalisme par accident
aussi après quelques années passées sur
les bancs de la fac de droit d'aix
voilà je tapote d'ailleurs mon écran
depuis 97 ou 98 et je me passionne pour
tout ce qui est
régulation réglementations et
législations
et voilà je travaille pour un ex
d'impact je suis rédacteur en chef qui
est mon seul et unique employeur et nous
avons yassir
jacir comme la cire est à coeur je vais
le laisser se présenter
car c'est un grand mot j'utilise
toujours avec des guillemets c'est un
bidouilleur
alors moi aussi il ya beaucoup d'hazard
dans mon parcours j'ai découvert le
hacking ya très longtemps parce que
j'avais créé un site web qui n'avait
aucun intérêt alors aucun et il s'est
fait hacker et je me suis posé plein de
questions à ce moment là comment
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des gens sur
internet qui voudraient ac est un site
qui n'a aucun intérêt donc c'est comme
ça que je suis tombé dedans portrait de
fil en aiguille j'ai travaillé dans des
boîtes de conseils puis j'ai monté une
petite boîte qui fait de la sécurité et
dernièrement une plateforme qui met en
relation les hackers et les entreprises
pour travailler ensemble et en parallèle
je suis tombé par hasard aussi dans mon
parcours dans ce qu'on appelle le média
citoyen où j'ai travaillé avec un
collectif qui s'appelait même ceux qui
ne vont couvrir l'actualité du monde
rare ab ce qui se passait dans cette
zone là je vais redonner la parole à
jean-marc manach jean marc manach on est
au 21ème siècle comment ça se passe sur
internet au niveau de la surveillance au
niveau du terroriste parce que là les
attitudes de nos gouvernements
respectifs on quelques résultats sur
internet concernant la guerre contre le
terrorisme
ben visiblement non victimes des
attentats
comment ça se passe ça se passe qu on
est encore majoritairement gouvernée par
des gens que ce soit du côté de
l'exécutif
on du côté des parlementaires qui ne
comprennent pas ce dont il est question
à la fois les questions relatives à
internet et les questions relatives aux
renseignements donc on est on est
gouverné par des parts des aveugles en
un sens c'est en tout cas des malvoyants
plus tôt dès que c est ce que c'est pas
un pour les journalistes ça
c'est un point de vue quelqu'un qui suit
ces questions depuis un certain nombre
d'années et est au niveau du
renseignement aussi on voit que c'est
pas bon pourquoi ils changent pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas la capacité
de s'intéresser ou de se remettre en
question à votre avis parce que c'est
pyramidale etc verticale il faut bien
comprendre que on commence un des
gouvernements commence par créer des
services de renseignement façon
clandestine qui n'existe pas
officiellement ensuite on découvre leur
existence ensuite les parlementaires et
l'exécutif décide de créer une loi pour
encadrer juridiquement les pratiques de
ses services de renseignement ensuite et
c'est ce qu'on a vu que la loi rend
sinon la technologie évolue fera ce
qu'il faut ce qu'on va revenir peut-être
20 11 la france est condamnée par la cdh
pour des écoutes téléphoniques fait edf
vous pouvez développer un des droits de
l'homme et donc ils votent une loi qui
encadre les écoutes téléphoniques
jusqu'à 91 les écoutes téléphoniques
n'existait pas officiellement mais pas
de cadre juridique mais bien sûr que les
existait depuis au moins 45 vu que les
les premières tables d' écoutes de la
police nationale en fait c'était l'étape
des coupes qu'ils avaient récupéré de la
gestapo la guerre 39-45 2,45 à 91 les
policiers les services de renseignement
écoutait en parfaite légalité de partir
de 91 c'est donc encadrée par la loi
avec un article 20 qui exclut la
surveillance du spectre hertzien de la
loi ce qui permet aux services de
renseignement notamment extérieure la
dgse de pouvoir écouter les satellites
se pose la question d'utiliser cet
article 20 pour écouter des téléphones
portables et là il ya la commission
nationale de contrôle des interceptions
de sécurité cncis qui est la commission
chargée de valider les techniques de
renseignement
qui explique aux services de
renseignements vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser l'article 20 pour espionner les
téléphones portables les téléphones
portables comme les lignes fixes vous
devez d'abord nous demander
l'autorisation et ensuite on vous la
corde ou pas il faut savoir que ces
dernières années grosso modo c'est un
peu plus de 6000 cible par an qui sont
écoutés par les services de
renseignement civils si vous parlez à du
premier échelon des coûts tout simule
cible à une équipe direct dirait et les
filets en direct ce serait bien que je
précise une cible ça peut être une
personne qui a cartes au sein qu'on dit
carte sim ou ça peut être un groupe de 2
3 4 personnes donc ça c'est les écoute
directe qui sont faites par le
groupement interministériel de contrôle
le jc et à côté de l'école militaire et
ils ont un quota qui a été élevé là
depuis les attentats de janvier ils
peuvent pas écouté plus de 2800 cible en
simultané voilà ça c'est pour les écoute
directe après il ya les systèmes de
surveillance
à l'étranger notamment lé c'est ce qu'on
appelle la surveillance internationale
donc ça c'est une des techniques de
renseignement qui a été légalisé par la
loi renseignements l'année dernière ce
qui s'est passé c'est que en 2008
nicolas sarkozy à part à signer un livre
blanc sur la défense dont qui donnait
la voie à suivre au ministère de la
défense dans les années à venir et il a
été décidé de surveiller internet donc
pour surveiller internet ils ont déployé
serez coûté 700 à 800 millions d'euros
ils ont déployé des systèmes de collecte
de masse au niveau des câbles sous
marins pour arriver à surveiller ce qui
rentre et ce qui sort à l'international
mais ils ont fait de même que la cncis
avait dans les années 90 ce qu'ils
appellent la jurisprudence créative une
jurisprudence créatif de la cncis c'est
quelque chose qui fait jurisprudence
mais qui n'est pas publié au journal
officiel c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
c'est pas un terme légal mais c'est un
terme consacré qui accélère très claire
marques qu'ils ont quelque chose précise
juste ce truc là sur la rue science
créative ils ont d'eux mêmes qu'ils ont
exclu l'assurance des téléphones
portables au motif de l'article 20 ils
ont accepté qu'une surveillance de
l'internet à l'international mais les
identifiants français devait être écrasé
on doit on ne peut pas utiliser ce
système de collecte de masse dessus
relance internationale pour surveiller
des français qui a été consacré dans la
loi
dans la loire enseignants l'année
dernière pourquoi pourquoi pas ce que la
cncis qui maintenant s'appelle cnct air
commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement estiment que
pour surveiller un français les services
de renseignement doivent d'abord
demander l'autorisation à la sienne
s'était auparavant à la cncis maintenant
la scène ctr par contre s'il s'agit de
surveiller un marocain un américain un
russe sur le territoire français sur le
territoire français sur le territoire
français c'est un petit peu compliqué la
lettre à l'étranger il doit la dgse doit
demander l'autorisation de surveiller un
pays tout ce qui va ou qui vient de la
syrie tout ce qui va ou qui vient de
l'état islamique tout ce qui a trait à
al qaïda
après pour ce qui est de surveiller
barack obama que ce soit sur le
territoire national ou surveiller barack
obama à l'étranger il n'y a pas de cadre
légal qui fait qu' ils doivent demander
l'autorisation à la cncis est un
étranger sur le territoire français est
ce qu'il ya besoin de passer par tout ça
après il ya tout ce qu'on ya les imsi
catcheur qui sont donc des valises
takis très souvent 62 valise mais qui
peut être camouflés dans les
camionnettes et qui permettent
d'identifier qu'il usurpe en fait est
une antenne de téléphonie mobile vient
même de lancer sa série un peu et voilà
ce qu'on attaque par l' attaque de
l'homme du milieu made in the middle qui
permet d'usurper une borne téléphonique
est donc d'arriver à identifier tous les
numéros inédits pour ça que ça paie les
musiques hatcher qui sont dans un
périmètre voir dit on pour des musiques
atur plus évolués d'arriver à écouter
des téléphones à la volée marque qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
ben pour un exécutif aveugle et sourd je
trouve qu'ils ont quand même pas mal de
dates appareillage auditif et aidé à la
visualisation sur les échanges alors
quelques précisions dès lors qu'on est
un des votes la question de la
surveillance
soit nationale sur internationale se
pose une question limpide tout simple et
bête et méchante à partir de quand une
communication nationale ou
internationale
pour faire simple la loi sur la
surveillance des communications des
communications internationales qui a été
adoptée après la loi sur le
renseignement qualifie comme tel
qualifie d' international une
communication dont au moins un des
identifiants de l'émetteur du récepteur
est situé à l'étranger dont on parle pas
de nationalité de la notion de français
ou pas français ça pas l'importance du
tout puisque on n'a pas des adresses ip
coloris colorisée en bleu blanc rouge
sur les écrans
et le spectre de lettre de la loi est
très intelligemment fait dans la mesure
où
si on qualifie comme telle une
communication dont au moins une adresse
ip et géo localisés à l'étranger
cela peut vouloir dire nous sans doute
par accident que
monsieur et madame michu qui échangent
en france entre paris et melun par
exemple via un outil
qui installe à l'étranger un petit
google ou microsoft tout ce que vous
voulez dans automatiquement si les
services du renseignement se focalise
uniquement sur l'adresse ip du service
intermédiaire à ce moment là les changes
entre franco français va être considéré
comme international et cette
qualification d'un international a des
conséquences
très lourdes en matière de formalisme et
d'accompagnement du contrôle de c2c de
ses outils de surveillance pourquoi
parce que
le la sienne ctr donc et la commission
nationale de contrôle technique du
renseignement n'interviennent pas a
priori pourrait mettre non pas une
autorisation mais un avis elle
intervient quatre posteriori on les fait
comment quand le mal est fait quand le
mal ou le bien et fait tout dépend
effectivement lorsque lorsque la
communication met en relation il
apparaît que après auscultation la
communication mais bien en relation deux
personnes installées en france
effectivement il faut basculer sur les i
sur les le formalisme franco-français
mais c'est trop tard tel qu'il savait
sur enseignement auront déjà eu la
formation par an
la commission donne son avis c'est le
premier ministre qui signe pour en
revenir souligné tout à l'heure
j'imagine pas du tout la dgse mettre sur
écoute barack obama ce sens que
l'exécutif n'ait valider ce genre de
choses peut être commandé la main pour l
écouter par la lfc l'exécutif il faut de
toute façon qu'à un moment il ya un
échelon qui effectivement valide le truc
parce que les petites mains qui ont
offert les écoutes faut pas prendre ce
genre d'initiatives pour rien d'accord
même même les petites mains qui fonde
les coudes sur des candidats députés
c'est ce qu'on a vu avec le très
intéressant la surveillance de thierry
solère on a donc le monde qui titre
comment la dgs va surveiller thierry
solère et ensuite l'article qui explique
que le service technique la direction
technique de la dgse a constaté un
détournement frauduleux
nick de renseignements dgse a avisé le
magistrat de lady g ce qui est dit mais
c'est illégal qui est lui-même a visé le
directeur de la dgse qui a fait cesser
le détournement frauduleux et ce qui est
assez bizarre c'est de voir que tout le
monde a repris le fait que la dgse a
surviré solaire alors que non ce qui
explique le monde sait que la dgse a mis
un terme à un détournement frauduleux de
ces techniques d'enseignement yassir
nous ont fait qu au milieu de tout ça
les entreprises comment ils font pour
éviter de se retrouver dans les mailles
du chalut très large des services de
renseignement et préserver un savoir
faire on fait comment pour très bonne
question alors que la situation
aujourd'hui elle assez chaotique
moi je fais partie de ceux qui croient
que dans ce cas hausse dans lequel on
baigne les hackers vont avoir un rôle à
jouer et je pense que c'est ce qu'on est
en train de ressentir petit à petit et
que tout le monde est en train de
prendre conscience que s'il ya une
population qui pourra aider aussi bien
les entreprises que les institutions
c'est scélérat coeur parce que dans
toutes ces situations là ce sont les
personnes qui ont le profil adéquat déjà
2 1 pour comprendre la complexité de
l'architecturé des architectures dans
lequel on baigne et de deux qui sont
armés pour pouvoir soit anticipée des
attaques soit répondre en cas d' attaque
donc aujourd'hui pourquoi ils sont
pourquoi ils sont c'est un vécu c'est un
vécu ce sont ces en dehors de la boîte
c'est ça alors il y a le fait moi je
donne toujours l'image de quand on
regarde par exemple internet et quand on
regarde le comportement des gens dessus
si on veut faire une analogie c'est
vraiment peu ferme à manger avec
l'architecturé urbaine vous avez les
citoyens les jours normaux qui vont
passer par le passage piéton et vous
avez les yamakasi quoi ceux qui font le
parcours qui vont passer par la fenêtre
c'est vraiment ça plus efficace c'est
pas plus efficace est vraiment une autre
lecture c'est à dire que compte on
regarde un browser on sait qu' à un
gendre ingelhein on sait qu'il ya un
moment un javascript ans et qu'à un
moment derrière il ya des va et vient
avec un serveur on sait qu'il ya une
librairie quelque part alors que pour
monsieur tout le monde c'est une adresse
sur laquelle on clique et il ya des
comptes du contenu qui s'affiche donc on
a une aventure de poncet qui est
différente voilà une manière de lire qui
est complètement différente et puis
aussi
c'est des gens qui très tôt on tombe
dans cette idée de bidouiller des
systèmes et donc ça devient un mode de
vie plus qu'autre chose donc aujourd'hui
on a regardé une affaire comme par
l'amateur c'est à dire quand on regarde
que leur world press le wtm cloud et est
accessible à monsieur tout le monde car
c'est peut-être dû chinois ce que je dis
mais en gros c'est un répertoire qui
contenait tous les fichiers de
configuration entre autres et ap on se
rend compte moi j'ai pas de doute sur le
fait qu'ils ont dépensé des fortunes
monstrueuse pour acheter des firewall ou
je sais pas quoi mais ils n'ont jamais
pensé à la confidentialité des aussi la
cas montre bien qu'en fin de compte la
sécurité plus un état d'esprit que juste
des investissements financiers dans du
matériel ou autre chose et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est en
train de réaliser ça et j'insiste
vraiment je pense que les hackers avec
les guillemets qu'on peut mettre parce
qu'il ya un glissement quand même
sémantique du terme qui est très souvent
mélangés avec des cybercriminels je
pense un peu de l'idéal de cette idée le
même gameplay ainsi qu'en france voilà
donc certains hausse et donnait le
terreau bidouilleurs quant à serge
pralat corsaire mais voilà c'est cette
population là va avoir un rôle
déterminant dans les années qui viennent
je pense qu'ils sont en train de se
repositionner au centre même de débat
que l'on gèle vous savez il ya il ya un
million d'utilisateurs de facebook qui
passe par tort qu'on voit que whatsapp à
implémenter un magasin de chiffres mon
poing un point qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
ya plus d'un milliard de personnes
utilisent whatsapp qui maintenant ces
chiffres est directement sous téléphones
portables et chiffré avec quoi
d'ailleurs ces chiffres et avec la cc
l'application c'est la librairie enfin
la libre et ses logiciels qui a
développé moxxi parkinson maxime roussy
qui est celui qui a développé signal qui
est une application qui marche sur ios
est sûre sur android et qui permet le
chiffrement points points c'est à dire
que le comptable message il en clair son
téléphone et quand on appuie sur rentrée
il est chiffré avec une clé de notre
correspondant donc ça circule sur les
réseaux de façon chiffrée sait
déchiffrer sur le téléphone du
correspondant et c'est extrêmement
simple à utiliser bout lien plus que
tout ce qui existait auparavant et par
un dernier point
le mois dernier google a annoncé à faire
un transparence thiery porte sur la
jetée pps depuis notamment les
révélations se donne de plus en plus de
serveurs chiffres les les transactions
ce qui circule sur le web et pour
prendre l'exemple des utilisateurs
français des différents services google
à l'exception de youtube 81% des
requêtes google sont aujourd'hui chiffré
donc même la dgse à l'international elle
voit passer du trafic chiffré donc
quelqu'un qui utilisent gmail avec
quelqu'un qui utilise une messagerie
hotmail partiront ils sont chiffrés
entre eux ça peut être intercepté sauf
que ça peut pas a priori des chiffres et
oui il ya une réponse parlementaire qui
sait qui est qui est très intéressante
sur ces questions-là de chiffrement rex
où je crois que c'était le ministère de
la défense ou de l'intérieur je m'en
souviens plus excusez-moi expliqué que
le chiffrement des flux finalement
c'était pas si embêtant que ça dans la
mesure où la loi les différentes lois la
loi sur l'enseignement la loi sur les
soldes la surveillance des
communications internationales on à la
loi sur la réforme pénale projet de loi
sur la réforme pénale qui est
actuellement discutée qui passera en
commission mixte paritaire dans quelques
jours autorise aussi bien les services
administratifs que les autorités
judiciaires à installer des chevaux de
troie bleu blanc rouge sur les
extrémités les communications donc du
coup on a beau avoir l'impression d'être
dans une bulle sécuriser un bon coeur et
des barreaux aux fenêtres dévoile des
rideaux noirs et serra en réalité bas
son téléphone peut très bien être
ausculté à distance par une autorité
sombre et cachés dans le coin de la rue
que je vais rebondir sur ça
j'ai à mes amis anciens de la dg ce que
vous connaissez tous
qui m'a parlé de 128 mo de mémoire dans
les contrôleurs clavier c'est pas beau
ça 128 mo de mémoire dans les
contrôleurs clavier c'est à dire que ça
peut stocker jusqu'à 2 millions de
frappes de vos claviers un quiz ailleurs
comment à qui le guen enregistreurs de
strates l'équivalent d'un kilo d'or mais
directement dans le matériel donc si
vous avez deux millions de frappes
stockées en clair faire c'est ce que
disait marc c'est à dire qu'en fait
chiffrer pour 1.6
variations
saran vias ça renvoie à l'idée du félidé
du back door en cours ou le cheval de
troie ou la porte dérobée
je pense que fondamentalement on pense
tout ça au débat qui a eu ou entre les
big apple où les bois et poussé epl pour
installer des c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
réactions assez bizarre en france 2 jean
députés qui soutenait l'idée qu'il
fallait mettre des backdoors hurler sur
les téléphones portables mais cela pose
un problème pourquoi y est sûre ça pose
un problème parce que cette idée là
fondamentalement et les foncières
m'embête c'est à dire que on va équiper
tous les téléphones iphone par exemple
pour ne citer que ceux là avec une porte
dérobée une porte dérobée c'est quoi
c'est un accès privilégié qui va être
détourné alors ça peut être la
possibilité d'avoir un accès distant une
sorte de lien par lequel on pourrait
arriver à une console d'administration
ou autre on pourrait installer un shell
qui permettrait à la personne qui allait
expliquer chez elle parce que tous à un
code sorte que ce code qui va s'exécuter
qui vous pourrez nous donner un accès à
distance ou voilà mais en tout cas c'est
cette idée de à l'insu de l'utilisateur
final on a la capacité d'accéder à des
données citons cloud et donc nous alors
c'est très très beau dans le monde des
bisounours parce que effectivement on
pourrait imaginer que ça pourrait être
utilisé pour traquer des méchants
toujours est il que cette porte dérobée
elle finit elle fait une finira par être
connu par tout le monde alors quand je
dis par tout le monde bien entendu ces
génies bien par des cybercriminels que
par des terroristes
et je ne pense pas qu'ils vont résulter
hésité à utiliser ça donc c'était assez
assez flippant quelques par de voir que
des gens ne percute pas encore le danger
que puisse représenter le fait d'avoir
des portes dérobées sur des machines
utilisées par des mines alors résumé
trivialement c'est l'équivalent de
donner un pass à toutes les autorités
qui sont censés inquiété et que si un
jour se passe tombe dans les mains de
personnes
mal intentionnées ça leur donne accès à
tous c'est à dire y compris roadie prix
les secrets de l'entreprise
écoutez un pdg c'est bien et coûtent un
pdg
marc
je vais simplement revenir sur le début
de la viande ou vous évoquez la lutte
contre le terrorisme et son efficacité
et jean marc disait très justement que
cette lutte a visiblement failli puisque
on a eu ces malheureuses attentats
je tiens à nouveau a précisé que la loi
ce renseignement et celle sur la
surveillance des communications
internationales n'est pas focalisé sur
le terrorisme le terrorisme c'est qu'une
brique dedans on a des idées on a de la
politique étrangère dalle
économiques plus larges économique et
sert à la lutte contre la criminalité
organisée ou fin plutôt la prévention de
la criminalité organisée et autre chose
au fil des débats parlementaires dans le
texte initial dans le projet de loi
initial qui avait été déposé par
christiane taubira le drian et les
casenoves il était dit que les services
devaient
assurer la défense d'une série d'intérêt
il avait cinq ou six en début d'échangés
parlementaires à la fin
de débat parlementaire cette notion de
défense a été enrichie avec celle de
promotion donc ce qui veut dire par là
c'est que les visions renseignements
peuvent aussi bien assurer la défense
des intérêts économiques français en
france comme à l'étranger mais également
faire en sorte de 2,2 de muscler ou de
promouvoir ses intérêts là
soit la planète entière c'est-à-dire
avoir un comportement prédateur et là on
parle en place d'une technologie de
défense intelligente attaque et ça peut
se cumuler et voilà le terrorisme même
si d'après les chiffres fournis par par
monsieur delon président de la
commission nationale de contrôle
technique des renseignements montre que
le terrorisme correspond à 40 % des avis
qui ont été délivrés par cette
commission depuis octobre entre octobre
et février
on a d'autres éléments comme ça qu'ils
rentrent dans la boucle et qui
permettent
aux autorités de flairer d'autres
d'autres flux qui ont envers son plumeau
de plus monétaire plus économique sur
dark jusqu'à l'année dernière
au niveau des interceptions ciblées donc
quand je parlais dissimulé grosso modo
interceptions c'était plus de 50% à 60%
c'était la lutte contre le crime
organisé et 30 % 7 et terrorisme donc là
depuis cette année on a effectivement un
accroissement en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme il faut bien comprendre
que l'essentiel du travail par rapport
aux écoutes téléphoniques des services
de renseignement ce crime organisé parce
que c'est les criminels sont plus
promptes à dire des conneries au
téléphone que 200 les terroristes jeu
maritime à côté une précision c'est les
chiffres qui sont données et par tous et
par mois le concerne que les dispositifs
de surveillance ou la vie de la scène
ctr est nécessaire a priori est donc là
pour la surveillance internationale où
on ne sait absolument rien évidemment
tout est couvert par le secret défense
donc là on n'a aucune visibilité sur le
sur la quantité d'informations et de
cette chose qu'on sait c'est légitime
ans et papiers de vincent jauvert qu'un
journaliste spécialisé sur ces questions
qui avait sorti en juillet s'est fait
beaucoup moins de bruit que la loi
renseignements mme un papier très
intéressant dans le nouvel observateur
et qui disait qu'il y avait chaque année
grosso modo une quarantaine soixantaine
de cibles étaient désignés pour la
surveillance internationale sachant
qu'une cible ça peut être un pays
voilà dernier point sur les chiffres
pour en revenir
au bac d'heure ou logiciel espion les
logiciels espions ont été autorisés il
ya quelques années en matière de police
judiciaire ce que là on ne parle que des
services de renseignement par les
écoutes téléphoniques en matière de
police judiciaire et un rapport très
intéressant de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement qui était
publié quelques mois expliqué que vu la
complexité technique et administrative
d'utiliser des logiciels espions depuis
2011 ils n'ont été utilisés que six fois
en matière de police judiciaire en
matière de police judiciaire en matière
de police judiciaire en france
on ne sait pas pour ce qui est des
services de renseignement par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est que ce même rapport de
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement expliqué qu' à ce jour les
logiciels espions n'ont pas encore été
dit croyez ça c'est un vrai problème de
2,2
est ce qu'on peut avoir confiance dans
quelle institution j'ai plus tendance à
voir mémoire sd dans une interview moi
j'ai un politique qui me disent ah que
on n'a pas la capacité de traiter tous
les flux d'informations ou les logiciels
espions tout le flux d'informations
qu'on peut faire émerger des logiciels
espions je les regarde droit dans les
yeux j'ai dit tu fous de ma gueule mon
pote parce que ce que dit jean marc ce
sont des magistrats qui fait mal au
sénat vous fêtez plaint justement de
disposer d'un outil juridique afin de
mener à bien des enquêtes extrêmement
intrusif pour la vie privée mais
justifiée par des finalités très
importante parce qu'on est là en termes
de criminalité informatique criminalité
organisée et de terrorisme on sait pas
rien mais il se plaignait justement d'un
manque de collaboration entre les
autorités administratives compétentes en
ce secteur là et puis le ministère de la
justice une espèce de de cassure comme
ça après ce qu'il en est réalité moi je
n'en sais rien je
répondre à des questions sur ce que
femme veut répondre avec l'asie est ce
que j'y crois le truc c'est qu'il ya
plein de choses que je ne sais pas parce
que j'ai pas le besoin d'en connaître
pour reprendre l'expression consacrée
aux services de renseignements par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il ya des choses que je peux que je
peux faire chier que je peux vérifier
donc non je n'ai aucun moyen de savoir
si c'est vrai qu'à 6 uniquement
logiciels espions qui aurait été
autorisé légalement par contre à partir
du moment où c'est un rapport officiel
qui est signé par des hommes par des
responsables politiques est signé par
des magistrats c'est engagent la parole
de l'état donc moi le jour où j'arrive à
démontrer que c'est faux je me ferai un
plaisir de faire le papier pour
l'instant tout ce que je peux dire si
rapporté les chiffres auxquels j'ai pu
accéder d'accord un complément parce que
je pense qu'on le dit à demi-mot depuis
le début mai qu'il faut insister dessus
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment se dire
que les logiques de guerre qu'on
connaissait sur des territoires
géographiques sont transposés dans ce
qu'on appelle le cyberespace des fois de
manière intelligente des fois de manière
beaucoup moins intelligente mais en tout
cas c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec les interconnexions qu'on a qu'est
ce qu'on en a par exemple des pays qui
pourraient être potentiellement des
cibles dans toutes les administrations
sens par exemple se retrouvent sur des
serveurs microsoft
donc potentiellement on pourrait accéder
à les finances de ce pays là les données
de santé les paiements des citoyens etc
etc vous imaginez bien que si vous avez
accédé à ces derniers la vous pouvez
quand même faire des choses assez
drapeau rouge mais on peut aller plus
loin dit cruijff cisco veille pour de la
honte peut arriver sur les architectes
ont par exemple sur des acheteuses
architecture pardon scada en couleur où
on arrive à quelque chose de très
industrielle des six industries et celle
informatiques qui contrôlent des
processeurs exactement voilà donc là où
l'impact il va être physique on peut
aller encore plus loin je joue pas la
personne qui veut faire peur mais je me
dis si l'on peut aussi fournir les
choses de manière assez lucide et froide
un moment pour se promener l'a emmené on
est en train de parler de quelque chose
qui est magnifique i et l'ail outil qui
est l'internet des objets à l'internet
des objets pour faire un moi j'aime bien
la définition de jeremy rifkin c'est la
rencontre du monde des digit et le monde
des atomes donc hongrois avec internet
on a construit une sorte de squelette et
puis là avec les capteurs on va venir
faire les terminaisons nerveuses quoi
donc on va pouvoir avec des sites web
interagir avec des choses du monde réel
donc vous imaginez bien que les pays qui
auront la capacité de contrôler ce genre
de choses ils pourront potentiellement
arrêtez arrêtez le courant électrique
dans un pays je me rappelle plus quel
rapport peut-être que vous allez vous
rappelez d'un rapport qui disait que aux
etats unis c'est une coupure
d'électricité pendant une semaine au
bout d'une semaine c'est des émeutes
quarante huit heures plus tôt c'était
l'attaqué avait fait eric filiol et qui
devait faire une conférence vous
étonnerai fait comprendre qu'il fallait
pas qu'il aille faire la conférence
était une donc du coup c'est il faut
quand même prendre conscience que c'est
pas juste je capte des informations ce
qu aux bonbons internet on le réduit à
je lis des messages et ça donne un côté
un peu
gentillet quam là où il ya vraiment de
vrais enjeux derrière et qu' il faut
qu'on se vend cela comme un vecteur
interceptions et si on n'a pas lu carl
von clausewitz sur la guerre totale on
peut pas appréhender correctement ce
qu'on peut faire avec intérêt deux
objets tout l'interception de des data
pour revenir sur
l'interception et la sphère immergée du
renseignements exploitables de tout
simple si on fait passer de
l'intelligence artificielle derrière ces
flux de données plus un bon opérateur
qui est capable de faire l'alliance
entre l'homme et la machine
ça va bien se passer on peut pas traiter
plus de six dossiers en même temps
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
à l'erreur
deux choses d'abord juste pour revenir
là dessus si c'était une interview qu'on
avait fait de bernard barbier que
l'ancien directeur technique de la dgse
donc c'est celui qui entre autres a
déployé c'était une collègue de masse
nouvelle assurance internationale qui
expliquait dans un documentaire qu'on a
fait sur la cyberguerre ya pas très
longtemps qu' il ya un problème avec
l'art d'informatique notamment l' arme
offensive enfin logiciel espion ou un
logiciel comme stuxnet qui est donc un
logiciel qui a justement fait dérailler
fait péter des centrifugeuses iraniennes
c'est que la grosse différence entre une
arme informatique et une bombe normal
c'est qu'une bombe normal quand ils
tombent elles explosent qui peut pas la
récupérer un logiciel comme stuxnet ou
un logiciel espion type de ceux qui sont
utilisés par la police judiciaire où les
des services de renseignement il explose
pas ils peuvent être conçus pour
s'autodétruire pour disparaître sauf que
en espèces ce texte net a été repéré et
qu' une des choses qu il expliqué c'est
que il est aussi très très attention aux
logiciels qu'ils utilisaient pour
s'infiltrer dans des serveurs parce que
si jamais ce davanture ils sont
identifiés par des adversaires ils
peuvent être réutilisés et c'était un
des problèmes auxquels les services
français américains et israéliens ont
été confrontés à ce texte est c'est que
maintenant les iraniens ont aussi ce
texte net et ils peuvent le détourner et
c'est le problème qu'on a rencontré
également avec le logiciel du hacking
team ou de fille de fisher alors hacking
kings qui est une entreprise italienne
qui développe un logiciel qui s'appelle
rcs ou délits les oromos trentre système
contre la distance qu'un logiciel qu'ils
disent ne vendre exclusivement à des
services de renseignements à des pays
qui vaut plus de 200000 euros à l'année
en règle générale donc savourer ça coûte
très très cher et qu'un logiciel espion
qui est conçu de telle sorte qu'il ne
puisse pas être reconnus par les
antivirus donc il ya eu ils ont fait
fine fischer c'est une entreprise
allemande qui développe un logiciel
équivalent une suite de logiciels
équivalents qui peuvent s'infiltrer que
ce soit sur des serveurs sur des
ordinateurs ou pour le contrôle de
téléphones portables par des techniques
qui sont maintenant relativement
documenté parce que justement ils ont
fait l'objet d'un piratage et que hiller
données internes ont été rendus publics
parce que légalement il ya eu des
logiciels de hacking team qui ont été
identifiés parce qu'on s'est aperçu
qu'ils avaient des dissidents des
journalistes qui avaient été espionnée
par ce logiciel là et que le logiciel
espion a été décortiquée par par une
université canadienne qui a expliqué
comment ça fonctionne donc on a plus de
visibilité et ça c'est une des choses
qui fait vraiment très peur à la fois
aux militaires aux services de
renseignements c'est qu'on arrive à
identifier une des raisons pour laquelle
il était vers caen suite aux révélations
snowdon c'est qu'ils arrivent à révéler
comment il fonctionne qu'est ce qu'ils
font parce que à partir du moment où on
sait comment ils procèdent est bon et
éventuellement de prendre des mesures
correctives confère le fait qu' il ya
plein de deux entreprises qui ont
recruté énormément de hackers depuis les
révélations snowdon pour durcir internet
c'était la fameuse phrase de bruce
schneier qui est un des meilleurs
experts et vulgarisateur en matière de
sécurité informatique qui disait que
pour lutter contre la surveillance de
masse il faut durcir internet pour faire
de telle sorte que massivement on
utilise le chiffrement et pour
contraindre les services de
renseignement à ne procéder qu'à des
interceptions ciblées oui mais on va
bien et bien montrer que
le chiffrement peuvent être excusés mon
expression mais on pouvait baiser le
chiffrement très facile de d'aisé le
chiffrement partir du moment où tu à
installer un logiciel espion dans le
terminal de la cible en question mais
c'est pas la même chose d'infiltrer les
terminales d'une cible en parts
l'étudiant que de surveiller intégralité
tous les français c'est pareil faut pas
croire que ce ne serait pas la même
chose que de casser la clé qui permet le
que c'est les clés c'est difficile alors
regarde presque bien différent d'un
gamin de logiciels espions je pense
qu'il est beaucoup plus de risques
d'avoir un logiciel espion installé dans
son ordinateur ou dans le mien de la
part de tes collègues de ton patron de
thé de ta femme de ton mec ou de
barbouzes surtout d'une entreprise
étrangère que d'un service de
renseignements qu'ils soient français ou
étrangers et je pense qu'on a beaucoup
depuis les révélations sonotone on s'est
focalisé sur la nsa sur le gchq ou qui
sont équivalents britanniques sur la
dgse mais on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de
ce que font les russes et de ce que font
les chinois et on a encore moins parler
de ce que font tous ces anciens des
services de renseignement qui bosse dans
les entreprises d'intelligence
économique
ou ou d'espionnage parce que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'espionnage
privé qu'il n'ya d'espionnage public
tout à fait mark mark matney enfin moi
quand j'entends tout ça je vois je vois
des oreilles des parts ou des yeux de
partout des dénés de partout des
moustaches les moustaches aussi qu'il
grandissait et
moi ce qui m'intéresse à dessus parce
que je je je trouve plutôt simple pour
un état
démocratiquement abouti d'avoir comme ça
une possibilité enfin un potentiel de
d'intrusion par rapport à des
infractions un risque infractionnelle
extrêmement grave il est normal et
d'ailleurs c'est le job de l'état est en
tout cas ces gouvernants que de prévenir
ces infractions là mais moi quand
j'entends tout ça ce qui dans ce ce
combat absolu entre la sécurité la
liberté c'est il se résout simplement
c'est l'organe de contrôle est l'organe
de contrôle aujourd'hui en france je
n'évoque même pas la communication des
communications internationales mais en
france
celui ci bon il faut lire un petit peu
les différents avis qui ont été
sécrétées par la scène ses terres depuis
octobre star sa mise en route depuis
octobre 2015 celle ci n'a de cesse de
dénoncer le manque de centralisation des
informations collectées parce qu'on a
effectivement dans la loi une panoplie
absolument folle d'outils intrusif qui
vont récupérer de la donne est partout
aussi bien sur le téléphone que sur les
flux externes etc mais ces informations
là pour qu'on puisse contrôler la
respectabilité de
la loi à savoir si les autorités ont
bien respecté les normes votées par les
députés et sénateurs eh bien il faut que
l'autorité de contrôle puisse contrôler
et il apparaît que faute de
centralisation des informations
collectées et ben l'autorisation de
contrôler la l'autorité de contrôle peut
difficilement contrôler l objet de
courir dans toute la france pour aller
collecter les données qui sont ils sont
glanées ici ou là alors est-ce que c'est
fait exprès pas exprès l'influencé
inhérents la technologie le truc c'est
que avant les écoutes téléphoniques
étaient centralisées au g10 et ils sont
encore centralisés gti c'est donc le
contrôle il est relativement simple à
faire une balise imsi catcheur quand tu
installes à marseille bah elle n'est pas
à côté de l'école militaire où jaillit c
est par définition les musiques hatcher
tu peux pas le centralisée et donc c'est
effectivement ce que ce que ce que
contestait l'ancien président de la
cncis ce pourquoi il n'a pas voulu
postuler à la cnct r c'est effectivement
il ya une impossibilité matérielle
de contrôle parce qu'on peut pas mettre
une personne du jc derrière chaque
balise musique hatcher qui peut être
utilisée qui sont en train de déployer
des systèmes pour arriver à faire
remonter les informations mais c'est
ça voilà c'est ça qu'on dit est
l'équivalent
d'avoir du nucléaire sans du contrôle du
nucléaire
pour revenir sur ta question à savoir ce
que c'est fait exprès ou pas
j'espère que non je note simplement que
dans l'étude d'impact lorsque un
gouvernement dépose un projet de loi il
doit impérativement associé celui ci à
une étude d'impact où il va essayer de
chiffres est
calibré l'impact économique des mesures
qu'il envisage de faire voter par les
députés sénateurs pourquoi pas ce que va
s'engager au budget le budget de la
nation budget public il faut qu'on sache
où va la contribution est curieusement
et s'était relevé par aucun député ni
sénateur
sauf erreur
le projet de loi sur le renseignement
est totalement silencieux sur le paquet
de biftons qui va être mis ou qui est
mis aujourd'hui sur le bureau de la
scène ses terres on a appris par la
suite que la scène ctr se verrait
attribuer quatre cent mille euros pour
l'année actuellement il ya neuf membres
plus cette personne employée à la fin
d'année il y aura une vingtaine de
personnes employés et voilà on a neuf
membres une vingtaine de personnes fin
2016 un budget de 400 mille euros tout
ça pour surveiller
théoriquement l'intégralité des flux qui
sont qui sont collectés ici et là ça
fait aussi bien aussi bien en contrôle a
priori pour la surveillance française
quand contrôle a posteriori pour la
surveillance française et internationale
ça me fait penser
sous dimensionné de
l'enquète parlementaire américaine sur
le 11 septembre
c'est extraordinaire non c'est dire que
vous avez une requête une enquête avait
une enquête vous avez une enquête est
lancée
et commence avec un budget très minime
qui est sans fond inférieurs à l'anc est
sur ma fondation de bill clinton jean
marc manach voulait dire quelque chose
fellation
du temps la cncis comme du temps de la
scène ctr leurs présidents respectifs
disent que même si effectivement ils
n'ont pas beaucoup de ils sont pas
nombreux quand il ya urgence il arrive
arrêt pendant quelques dizaines de
minutes ou en moins de 24 heures au pire
où en es en deux heures quand il ya
vraiment urgence donc c'est pas le
problème d'effectif ne se portent pas
par rapport à l'urgence le problème
effectivement là c'est qu'il ya plus de
techniques de renseignement qui ont été
validées par la loi qui existait déjà
auparavant c'est juste mais pas de cadre
légal qui ont un permettez-moi caution
je vous entends dire ça j'ai
l'impression d'entendre les gens du
nucléaire me direz vous inquiétez pas on
n'a qu'une capacité de réaction qui est
extraordinaire regarder fukushima on a
tout bien géré non ça fait pas un peu
quand tu es plus comme s'il y avait
un camion qui tournait avec des flingues
que n'importe qui pouvait rentrer dedans
et servir avec un flingue et c'est cher
et continuer de tourner peut tout à fait
d'accord que là je ne fais pas assis
derrière ça fait décider un an pour
reprendre une expression antoine
champagne c'est on n'y a pas ça ça va
pas la même le même niveau de létalité
physique que le nucléaire pour l'instant
et qui leur parle
ils sont les morts les morts si moi je
m'amuse à l'ehess qui côté un petit peu
les centrales nucléaires t'inquiète pas
que et après les morts on peut les
trouver autrement c'est-à-dire dans la
capacité à géolocaliser des gens qu'on
veut éliminer ça oui ça après on peut
après faire l'exercice de se dire c'est
pas direct c'est pas mort directe de la
chine pendant des siècles avait intérêt
à être territoire une démocratie peut
tomber quand même non pendant des
siècles les programmes neufs car on veut
que le kilo cher je vous trouve parlons
d'être
ici des boîtes noires les bonheurs c'est
la chose qui a fait le plus flipper
l'opinion publique et pas seulement
l'opinion publique les médias j'ai
jamais vu autant d'oppositions
si tu me paraît tout couper j'ai pas
peur des boîtes noires moi
personnellement je sais mon préserver ça
me fait pas peur moi ce qui me fait peur
c'est qu'on donne tout un tas de lames
de rasoir à les incompétents avec une
parole démocratique française qui ait
souillé et des lames de rasoir dans un
contexte économique gravissime où la
guerre clanique faire un geste elle
s'est jusqu'alors elles existent elles
sont plus visés ses fins mais qu' il n'y
avait pas de cadre légal qui ont péri en
autorisé mais officiellement
l'utilisation
il ya deux il ya deux nouvelles
techniques de renseignement qui ont été
introduites dans la loi renseignement
qui n'existait pas auparavant la
première c'est les fameuses boîtes
noires en fait les boîtes noires c'est
quoi c'est un fail politico médiatique
c'est un conseiller ministériel qui
campent devant des journalistes me
demander mais c'est quoi la surveillance
algorithmique les algorithmes de de
surveillance vous voulez légalisé dans
leur enseignement le conseil ministériel
en question a dit vous inquiétez pas
c'est des boîtes noires ya rien qui en
sortira depuis c'est devenu un phénomène
les boîtes noires alors qu'en fait on
parle bien de cet algorithme de
surveillance
et en fait c'est quoi c'est parce que la
technologie évolue et ils ont si ils ont
légalisé donc ses algorithmes de
surveillance en se disant bon bah on
sait pas comment la technologie va
évoluer mais on va se permettre un
algorithme de surveillance ça veut tout
dire et n'importe quoi c'est à dire un
logiciel grosso modo donc on va voir on
légalise ça dès maintenant comme ça on
aura déjà un cadre légal le giron voudra
les mettre en oeuvre la deuxième mesure
qui était qui n'existait pas auparavant
et qui a été légalisé par l'ats laurence
énoncé la surveillance en temps réel des
métadonnées de tous ceux qui
communiquent avec les cibles ce qui
représente une menace pourquoi parce
qu'on avait découvert suite aux
attentats de charlie que les frères
kwasi et coulibaly ne communiquait pas
directement avec leur téléphone on est
passé par là et les téléphones de leurs
conjointes respectives donc pour arriver
à identifier des nouveaux terroristes
ils veulent surveiller les métadonnées
du tout ce que communique avec les y va
c'est pas que comme ça
c'est compact et fils en un an mais sans
trahir les jours sans trêve mais source
mais bon je pense que je vais être
encore écouter pour les 50 prochaines
années il passait aussi par des boîtes
mails non pas du tout je sais pas il se
laissait pas des petits messages dans
les poubelles des boîtes mails ou dans
les jeux ne s'agit pas encore envoyé non
g skill et kwasi coulibaly je sais pas
rires à d'autres difficilement à 6 10 et
des acquis mais juste revient soit il
voulait leclerc devant on sait
simplement tu prends n'importe quelle
boîte mail tu laisses un message dans le
dossier pour envoyer tu fais le code à
ton pote et puis utiliser le général
petraeus avec sa maîtresse et c'est
pourquoi l'affairé aux états unis cescut
certains terroristes auraient utilisé ce
escutes il vise également un des
journalistes de cash investigations avec
le lanceur d' alerte au luxembourg c'est
comme ça que ça va changer les idées
mais sachez une des techniques utilisées
je reviens jouer sur la loire
entraînements donc c'est ce sont les
deux innovations dans la loire
anciennement de choses qui n'existaient
pas auparavant et j'en reviens un
rapport de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement il ya une note de bas
de page la mode 67 ou 128 je sais pas
quoi qui dit que du fait de la
complexité technique et administrative
la surveillance en temps réel des
métadonnées d'une part et les fameuses
boîtes noires les algorithmes de
surveillance des comportements suspects
d'autre part ne sont pas mis en oeuvre
aujourd'hui donc l'essentiel du débat
l'année dernière a porté sur quelque
chose qui n'existe toujours pas à en
croire la délégation dans la prise et
design etc et d un design et pour être
utile si oui mais pour l'instant ça
reste effectivement de l'onu menace
virtuelle et moi ce que j'ai vu et
d'expliquer l'année dernière c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'on entendait à
savoir que les boîtes noires les
surveillants l'intégralité de tout
trafic des français les journalistes
détriment double retenant une étude de
chercheurs de l'inria qui est dit que
c'était complètement débile parce que si
on surveille 66 millions de français
avec un taux d'erreur même si ces 99 %
taux d'erreur énormément de gens qui
n'ont rien à se reprocher qui sont
surveillés sauf que les services sont
pas complètement débile pour voir sur ei
66 millions de français d'une part et
que d'autre part techniquement parlant
c'est impossible d'assurer l'intégralité
du trafic internet français parce qu'il
faut déployer 50 à 70 mille boîtes
noires au niveau des des slams parce que
l'internet est décentralisée il ya des
paquets qui vont passer par rennes des
paquets qui vont passer par lille et que
pour arriver à effectivement à regrouper
ses paquets là bas il faudra mettre des
boîtes noires un peu partout et que ça
coûterait des milliards d'euros et que
voilà donc tu me parle de nucléaire je
te renvoie les boîtes noires il faut
bien c'est un truc de base en matière de
sécurité informatique c'est le modèle de
menaces quel est le modèle de menaces
auxquelles on est confronté moi ce que
je découvre en enquêtant ce que 30 où on
a commencé à parler de la nsa moi j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à la dgse pour
voir qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient et ce
qui est très intéressant de voir c'est
que pour une bonne partie du débat
concernant les moyens des services de
renseignement laisse entendre que sont
ils font exclusivement la surveillance
de masse surtout de la surveillance de
masse alors que moi ce que je vois c'est
que ces boues beaucoup plus de
surveillance ciblée ne serait ce que
parce qu'ils sont pas non plus sans 1300
milles et que des gros volumes de
données il faudra un fondement des
analystes à 1 et ça ils sont moins de
50000 à la dgse ils sont moins de 6000
et ils n'ont pas que ça à par
ailleurs marc oui j'étais là moi lors de
cette confiance est un micro conférences
de presse où le mystère le gouvernement
allait expliquer à trois vagues de
journalistes la loi renseignements
qu'ils allaient déposer à l'assemblée
nationale quelques jours plus tard
effectivement ce conseil technique a
évoqué ce terme de boîtes noires mais
dans un sens
positif à savoir que pour lui s'il avait
cette logique aéronautique on avait une
boîte noire qui allaient être installés
chez des pilotes d'avion un peu bizarre
qui sont les opérateurs et où
l'opérateur n'aurait aucun droit
d'entrée de contrôle de connaissances
donc faites nous confiance voilà
effectivement effectivement il ya eu un
effet boomerang
voilà ma pré bon c'est le jeu après
effectivement comme tu dit jean-marc on
va pas écouté tout le monde mais
j'allais dire et alors
je dis est alors face ça change
absolument rien parce que lorsqu'on tue
avance ainsi
tu avances de tels des arguments on
pourrait croire en creux ou a contrario
que dans la mesure où ça pète ça pète
tout le monde bat finalement c'est un
peu moins grave non enfin pour moi et je
me fiche totalement de savoir si le jeu
boîte noire va va va récolter va glaner
chaluter latéralité de données ou la
moitié des données de la population
française ou un tiers ou un sentier -
millième fois non ça n'a aucune
importance ce qui m'intéresse plus
si cette notion de contrôle
sur sur le possible champ du possible de
des services
sur lui l'analyse que va pouvoir avoir
toujours la scène ctr un peu obsédé par
elle mais parce que c'est le dernier
verrou avant du n'importe quoi et pour
l'instant moi j'ai pas de réponse je
défie quiconque d'avoir des réponses
dans la mesure où tout est classé
défense c'est que défendra bien rebondir
sur deux choses qui aurait plaisir
lorsque ça va être intéressant puisque
depuis tout à l'heure en parle beaucoup
de ses classiques en parle beaucoup de
sécurité on oublie la sûreté on parle
beaucoup de sécurité informatique et les
deux cents liée là pour faire un
distinguo rapidement la sécurité ça va
être pour lutter contre ce qui est
volontaire d attaque volontaire auquel
cas a volontairement voulu endommagés là
où il les assure t ça serait comment
lutter sur contre des choses qui
seraient involontaires l'accident quoi
et je pense que c'est vrai qu'il faut se
poser aussi cette question là et qu'elle
est très souvent il lucide et donc ça
c'est juste une remarque au passage
l'idée et je vois là il dit et
j'aimerais bien revenir sur la sphère
hacking team parce que moi je connais
très bien cette affaire puisque moi
j'étais dans un collectif qui a priori
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on a été
attaqué par un parent un outil de
akli team ça va beaucoup plus loin que
des justes des des outils de contrôle à
distance parce que eux ils récupérer ce
qu'on appelle du zéro des musées rodez
ce sont des failles de sécurité qui
n'ont pas du tout encore été patché
inconnu par les éditeurs et donc après
plage saisir pas encore corrigée par par
l'éditeur en question et donc du coût en
termes d'impact autant que ça n'a pas
encore été connue par l'éditeur l'impact
peut être foudroyante parce que toutes
les machines qui sont équipés ou
potentiellement qu'il contient de cette
vulnérabilité sont susceptibles d'être
attaqués et on peut exécuter des
d'exploit dessus donc ce que faisait
cette boîte c'est que l récupérer des
héros d il est embarqué n'importe
comment un peu dans des dents des outils
et puis ça a été notre csa a été revendu
un peu partout à priori à des
gouvernements et donc ça renvoie à cette
question de se dire
une fois que les tout le code source de
hacking team s'est retrouvé dans la
nature puisque à leur tour ils ont été
hackés moi je m'en tiens l'idée qu'on
s'est retrouvé quand même avec une sorte
de da garage avec plein d'armes
informatique ou cyber si on veut faire
le distincts et dans lequel plein de
plein de monde se sont servis et puis
même les terres si utiliser ces outils
là commence à se dire avant est-ce que
je sais très bien utiliser ce que moi
même je peux pas me faire attaquer mais
moi ça je vais aller encore plus loin ça
ça pose la question de la réglementation
c'est à dire cette boîte fondée
légalement
du zéro day quoi ils vont des légalement
des outils pour attaquer donc quelques
nikov disponibles nous y voilà ses
services et il ya une vraie réflexion
sur ce marché-là est sûre est ce qu'on
peut vendre est-ce que ça fait sens de
vendre des vulnérabilités comme ça non
patchées inconnus qui peuvent avoir des
impacts aussi dramatique alors on va
changer de sujet on va parler des
whistleblowers
je vais donner la parole à jean-marc
jean-marc les whistleblowers clausen à
son jeune on est où là l'asie l'asile de
en france la position de michel sapin
sur les lanceurs d'alert il se passe
quoi en france on fait des donuts ne
donne à alerter la france on a vraiment
voulu défendre lanceur dallaire donc
accueilli moi mais ils font pas ils vont
pas le faire cesser
il faut comprendre que
c'est les fameuses file donc les files
et les services de renseignements
américains britanniques canadiens néo
zélandais et australiens qui ont formé
cette alliance dans les années 50-60 où
il partage plein de renseignements que
tout ce que collecte l'année ça n'est
pas partagée avec les files mais une
bonne partie de ce qui les collectent et
derrière il ya ces terrains des graves
qui avaient été publiées dans le cas des
révélations snowdon il ya les knight
rises les isles en fait ces décès des
accords de partenariat il faut voir ce
que font les services de renseignement
comme une place de marché c'est à dire
que je te file temps donné tu me files
telle technologie il ya vu cette une du
monde et quelques il ya deux trois ans
qui avait dit que la naissance espionner
70 millions de communications
téléphoniques de français les majors
c'est plus sain en fait c'était pas ça
c'était 70 70 millions de métadonnées
qui avait été intercepté à l'étranger
sur un théâtre de guerre d'opérations
par la dgse qui avait été partagée à
part la dgse qui avait partagé ou au
five guys on sait qu'il ya des accords
de partenariat entre la dgse digestive
hq où tu me donne tant de millions de
métadonnées qui viennent de tels pays et
je te file temps millions de métadonnées
parce qu'ils ont des objectifs conjoint
ils sont ensemble dans la lutte contre
dahesh par contre ça va pas empêcher la
dgse pouvoir espionner des américains et
des américains de pour espionner les
français comme on l'a montré la pâte et
guerlain ces désaccords entre les
services de renseignement pour partager
des technologies et partager du
renseignement alors dans l'est dans les
files je veux bien que et donc comme ils
ont des accords et ben ils vont la
france ne va pas accueillir edouard
snowdon parce que dans ce mode n'est pas
un ami des états unis mais moi je vois
plutôt ça du mans où il voit plutôt ça
différemment
c'est bien on vois plutôt ça comme une
technique de mafieux qui dit voilà tués
attaqués par al qaïda si tu ne me donne
pas accès à des renseignements je ne te
donnerai plus accès au mam ou
renseignement s'est passé pendant la
première guerre du golfe les militaires
français se sont aperçus que les
militaires américains refusaient de leur
montrer certaines photos satellites ce
pourquoi l'armée française est créée la
direction du renseignement militaire drm
pour arriver justement un pouvoir avoir
des satellites espions que ce soit pour
espionner des le spectre hertzien les
des radars ou pour prendre des photos
satellites la france est un des rares
pays au monde à avoir effectivement de
capacités de renseignement satellitaires
et c'est parce que les américains
refusaient de partager marc est ce que
michel sapin se fout pas un peu de la
gueule du monde quand il dit qu'il veut
protéger l'ancien lettre d' alerte
j'attends que les différents textes qui
sont en discussion soit c'est vrai que
vous faites vous faites un travail de
moine bénédictin sur le texte de loi et
on tient tous à vous remercier et
benjamin bayart aussi de ce côté moines
bénédictins parce qu'il faut vraiment
qu'il y en ait qui gère les mateurs
ouais en fait c'est accessible à tout le
monde enfin si on a un petit bagage
initial ça accessible à tout le monde il
suffit simplement de se plier sur le
sida le sida sans nationale ou du sénat
regarder les amendements qui sont
déposés à droite à gauche peur et des
sénateurs députés et par le gouvernement
et essayer de renifler quel sera
l'avenir il ya les tous les outils sont
là il ya cas en l'espèce la note de bas
de page sur les boîtes noires qui
n'existe pas il y avait je sais pas
combien d'articles l'année dernière sur
les boîtes noires il ya aucun article de
presse ana connaissances sur cette note
de bas de page qui pourtant est une
information plutôt intéressantes sur les
côtés de justin qui travaillent parce
qu'il ya encore un autre terme dont on
parle souvent les méthodes les
métadonnées peut-être que ça parle pas
tout le monde mais en beauce et des
données sur les données angotti envoie
le message et la met à data ça va être
l'heure à laquelle ça a été envoyée
douce a été envoyée qui a envoyé qui a
reçu donc quand on parle de métadatas
c'est de la donner sur de la donner en
gros pour lewis et le blog je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a un problème de
statut c'est à dire que il ya une sorte
de laisser un peu là là c'est classique
à l'apparition d'un rôle dans une
société où dans une organisation vu tout
dire qu'aujourd'hui le whistleblower un
statut bord que l'opinion publique lui
reconnaît mais il n'a pas du tout de ce
statut légal et c'est pas la même chose
parce que il peut être il peut avoir
tout le soutien moral du monde
légalement on peut l'emprisonner on peut
le poursuivre il peut avoir de sacrés
problèmes et je pense que ce qui est en
train de se jouer aujourd'hui c'est
cette capacité à créer un statut légal
pour ces individus et le cadre est au
milieu de contraintes qui dépasse juste
des espaces géographiques localiser
puisque comme tu disais très bien on se
retrouve dans des personnes qui peuvent
avec leurs révélations embarqué tout un
réseau international dans une affaire
voilà qui deviendra une affaire
géopolitique donc je pense que là
aujourd'hui c'est ce moment là on
pressent qu'on va réussir à passer d'un
statut moral vers un statut légal
reconnu par la loi qui va de pour le
moment
c'est pas clair c'est parce que j'en
avais marre
ça c'est extrêmement complexe à un
encadré juridiquement c'est
effectivement cette dichotomie entre le
moral et puis le juridique enfin
franchement le pont est pas simple mais
j'ai la confortable place de pet
législateur heureusement et voilà il ya
une tentative qui actuellement menées en
matière de failles informatiques
ce que vous savez que lorsque vous avez
système informatique vous rentrez dedans
déjà si vous rentrez dedans sans
autorisation ce une infraction pénale si
vous maintenez à l'intérieur c'est une
infraction pénale si vous modifiez des
éléments c'est une infraction pénale
plus grave donc toute une échelle comme
ça de deux peintres et préprogrammés
problème que se passe-t-il lorsqu'un
bluetouff par exemple trop une faille de
sécurité sur un sur un système
et les bruits tu vois là ou alors le
souffle l'existence de cette faille de
sécurité à l'éditeur du système en
question
donc l'actuel moi même des attaques dont
je parle connu en france oui voilà alors
naturellement il ya un texte qui est en
gestation je crois que c'est sur le
projet de loi sur la réforme pénale j'ai
peut-être un doute parce que
voilà et qui vu vise à ce que les
lanceurs d'alertés matière informatique
soit finalement excusé de leurs
interventions de la rentrée de la stam
alors d'excusés ça veut dire dispensé de
peine de penser dollars
c'est là où ils sont pas dispensés de
poursuites c'est à dire 3 seront
poursuivis ils seront jugés mais juste
avant la condamnation avant que le
bourreau appuyé sur sur le bouton rouge
et ben non la dispense de peine sera là
sauf que quand vous travaillez dans la
sécurité informatique qui vous avait un
casier judiciaire c'est compliqué quand
même c'était extrêmement compliqué voilà
d'autant plus qu'un amendement qui a été
qui est poussé par par l'opposition qui
voudrait que finalement ce soit ce soit
pas ce système là qui qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient adoptés en france mais un
mécanisme où les bluetouff de france et
de navarre viendrait soufflé à l'oreille
de landecy l' agence nationale de la
sécurité c'est un information
l'existence d'une faille de sécurité
chez x ou y afin que celles ci puissent
prendre les mesures d'hygiène
informatique afin de colmater tout ça
mais là encore c'est c'est bien beau
mais ça ne tardera pas à l'éditeur
propriétaire de systèmes informatiques
d'attaquer ce bluetouff en question qui
vient qui vient prêter pénétrer ses
plates bandes c'est un sujet qui me
parle encore beaucoup parce que voilà on
parlait tout à l'heure je travaille sur
une plate forme que j'ai créé avec
d'autres habits sap ailier gauche à qui
met en relation les hackers avec les
entreprises ils ont fait ce qu'on
appelle du bug bounty c'est à dire que
l'entreprise
aujourd'hui les entreprises qui
acceptent de payer les hackers qui leur
détecte des failles de sécurité et je
pense que ici une nouvelle voie qui est
en train de se dessiner et qui va
justement à mener à créer une sorte de
marché légal transparent dans lequel on
rentre dans un process de service c'est
à dire que le hacker va dire à tel site
regardez ici vous avez telle faille et
l'entreprise va reconnaître ça comme une
vraie transactions professionnelles et
va payer pour pour le service avec en
prime une incitation face à celle de
chips je te donne ici la réponse des
opposants est-ce que c'est pas une prime
espèce de carottes 1 à zoug à ce que des
tft est un petit peu sauvage on soit
mené sur tel ou tel système absolument
pas parce que c'est des choses qui sont
très cadré il faut savoir que c'est un
modèle qui existe par ailleurs un aux
etats-unis c'est pas quelque chose qui
on n'a pas réinventé la roue c'est
quelque chose qui existe par ailleurs et
qui marche très très bien l'idée c'est
que de 1 en quoi ça inciterait les gens
à tester de manière sauvage la deuxième
chose qu'il faut savoir c'est que
nous par exemple on sélectionne les gens
qui travaillent sur la plateforme c'est
pas un truc ouvert où n'importe qui peut
venir faire n'importe quoi donc à partir
du moment où il ya une vraie sélection
et qu' il ya un rapport enfin une
plateforme bien qu'ils cadrent les
choses qui offre ce cadre légal et qui
en plus offrent toutes les protections
va dire technique en disant interdit
d'utiliser des scan automatique interdit
de faire ça il faut travailler de telle
plage horaire at-elle plages horaires
les hackers sont des gens qui
connaissent à qui le font par ailleurs à
dire avec des plateformes américaines
par exemple donc ils sont ils ont
parfaitement tout ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir faire le même service avec des
entreprises françaises qui joueraient le
jeu quoi sur moi et sur l'idée juste je
finis sur l'idée de l'autre cas limites
ou un hacker serait fuite et c'est vrai
qu'il ya une différence culturelle par
exemple avec les états unis les états
unis est ce qu'on appelle le full
disclosure à dire que hacker va
soumettre à
il pourrait dire par exemple une faille
est une entreprise et si l'entreprise ne
se réveille pas ou ne fait rien il va le
rendre public et la sécurité c'est aussi
ça c'est à dire au bout d'un moment et
ça marche très très bien venir au bout
d'un moment une entreprise qui fait pas
son travail qui ne protège pas une 3d je
parle pas il faut en parler et il faut
qu'ils se bougent le cul quoi c'est au
bout d'un moment il n'y a pas de mal à
cesser cette culture là n'existe pas
encore en vente en france
mais je pense que ça va venir d'autant
plus qu' il va y avoir par exemple un
amendement qui se prépare qui est déjà
passée loup à la la la la cyber
directive sur la protection des données
personnelles ci n'est pas de bêtises ou
où les toute entreprise qui ne
communiquerait pas sur une perte ou d où
un vol des données de ses utilisateurs
se verrait à avoir une amende de 5 % du
chiffre d'affaires une broutille fall
actuellement cette obligation existe sur
les épaules des opérateurs télécoms
voilà même à l'etranger d'accès g j
droit français été mis à jour donc la
cnil peut être informé et si jamais le
la cnil estime que le fournisseur
d'accès n'est pas super coopératif
elle a la possibilité de lui ordonner
d'alerter l'ensemble de son parc
d'abonnés donc c'est assez douloureux
comme madoff parce que en ce milieu
puisque l'argent c'est la confiance
palin la rebelle hutu donc l'herbe alors
orange à free un peu importe oui alors
un dernier mot sur les lanceurs
d'alertés j'en profite pas eu la parole
il devrait cinq minutes votre dernière
question ce sera à l'essai un conseil
pour les jeunes générations ça fait une
heure qu'on est déjà ensemble jean-marc
les whistleblowers et tout suffire il
entendait on en a jamais eu autant de
lanceurs d'alerté il ya jamais eu
également aux états unis autant de
lanceurs des rays qui sont poursuivis
par l'espionage act sous obama y en ait
autant que depuis 1917 donc c'est une
vraie lame de fond ça continue et que ce
soit du côté des militaires on l'a vu là
du côté des banques donc ça c'est une
sorte de cercle vertueux cessé il ya
snowdon qui vient de signer un papier la
questure teaser sur des intercepts qui
les présente comme des nouveaux
résistants on a eu un lanceur de l'année
70 maintenant il y en a plein donc ça
s'est très très bien après sur les
limites du contrôle légal de ce que peut
faire la loi on a vu suite au printemps
arabe quand on a découvert effectivement
que des entreprises occidentales avaient
de données des logiciels de surveillance
des logiciels espions faire données
vendus à des dictateurs ils ont changé
les accords de wassenaar wassenaar c'est
la régulation des biens à double usage
des biens qui peut être utilisée pour
des utilisations civiles ou militaires
et dort normalement aujourd'hui une
entreprise française qui veut vendre un
logiciel espion un système de
surveillance un pays étranger doit
demander l'autorisation à matignon donc
ça c'est bien a priori dans la loi sauf
qu'on n'a pas de visibilité là dessus on
sait pas exactement comment c'est fait
et on a vu que plusieurs entreprises
françaises se sont délocalisés à
l'étranger dans des pays qui n'ont pas
signé les accords de wassenaar pour
pouvoir continuer à vendre leurs
systèmes de surveillance donc c'est les
limites de la légalité
barque un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
là les enfants les enfants mais valeur
leur camp les slovaques ont fait
immortel dans leurs interviews
ça n'a pas de super sexy mais justement
je pense que je les inciterai et là
j'essaye tout doucement des initiations
à suivre les débats parlementaires parce
que c'est là oui c'est là où tout se
passe réellement ça où tout se passe
mais bon c'est bon c'est mon adn aussi
ces masses maddock ma drogue mais suivre
les débats parlementaires sur des
questions de société qui peuvent les
intéresser potentiellement c'est
fondamental parce que le politique est
obligé de sortir du bois on a des
députés qui sont qui sont un petit peu
un petit peu pénible qui pose les bonnes
questions et les noms des noms des noms
je sais pas moi y'a lionel tardy et bela
tarr
christian paul patrick bloche notamment
lorsqu'ils sont dans l'opposition
voilà on a quelques déplier comme ça qui
vous qui sort qui sorte qu'ils peuvent
sortir du lot selon le contexte
environnant et et qui peuvent qu'ils
peuvent comme ça à nourrir le débat et
puis contraintes de politique quelle que
soit sa couleur jean-marc un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
vérifiez si on vous dit quelque chose si
vous voyez quelque chose il risque un
lien rester une source regardez le code
source d'un logiciel apprenez à coder ou
si vous n'apprenez pas à coder apprenez
à comprendre le code à le dire le code
source c'est parce que sinon si vous
êtes juste des poules moutons
noirs des pour nom et moi ce qui me fait
le plus l'ipc que quand je suis quand je
suis arrivé sur internet à la fin des
années 90 il y avait quelques
théoriciens de la conspiration quelques
conspirationnistes qui parlait d'une
d'illuminati et c2 reptilien le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est dans la cour
de collège et que et pas que dans les
cours de collège c'est aussi des de plus
en plus de gens notamment à l'extrême
droite qui désirent complètement
conspirationnistes et c'est le truc qui
me fait le plus flipper c'est ça en ce
moment c'est des gens qui partent
complètement vrille à croire n'importe
quoi et aussi je le déplore l'année
dernière avec la loi renseignement j'ai
vu plein de trucs de gens qui avaient
peur mais en fait si on vérifie si on
aussi on regardait si on se renseignait
on aurait beaucoup moins peur et en a et
je pense que on a moins peur de ce qu'on
connaît c'est pas un peu la faute des
journalistes qui au temps de
conspirationnistes maintenant ce que
comme ils ont pas fait leur taf pendant
un temps
on revient au papier on en revient à
l'histoire de la surveillance de thierry
solère le monde fait un titre avec un
article qui dit le contraire de ce que
dit le titre la totalité de la presse
reprend le titre alors que toute la
presse allez yassir le mot de la fin à
difficile de donner un conseil dont je
rejoins bien sûr
genre manach sur l'idée qu'ils faut
regarder le code s'est intéressé à la
technologie d'autant plus qu'on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec l'internet
des objets on va baigner dans des dans
des sociétés où ça va être vraiment
quelque chose d'important je pense qu'il
ya aussi une petite réflexion a partagé
ses devoirs la technologie comme un
pharmaco reprend l'idée de stieg l'air
qui est il faut le voir comme aussi bien
le médicament l'antidote que le poison
et donc la capacité à ne pas trop
s'enthousiasmer pour la technologie est
pas non plus partir sur quelque chose de
dramatique avoir toujours cet équilibre
de se dire on peut bien l'utiliser on
peut ne pas bien l'utiliser comme on
peut bien l'utiliser quelles seraient
les dangers de l'utilisation de la
technologie la technologie reste que
même quelque chose d'objectif en soit
c'est l'humain qui est subjectif
messieurs merci je voulais vous
remercier vous remercier au nom de notre
communauté est devenu on aurait pu
discuter des heures et des heures avec
vous j'espère qu'on pourra ré organiser
un débat pour creuser plus en profondeur
les sujets qu'on a évoqué aujourd'hui
monsieur bonne journée
[Musique]